my whole mouth is alive it's so spicy my
scalp is itching
my scalp it's just just a little bit
tell me more about your okay
welcome to America
I'm in food Paradise so you grew up
eating like this pretty much must be sad
for you when you have to eat out
there's always something new to discover
I've never butchered the face of
anything in my life we're gonna skip the
gloves okay a little bit more sensual
for me you're the pig
[Music]
come with me as I travel and taste the
nation every dish on the truck is 50
Pakistani 50 Appalachian look at that
goodness it's all about texture
oh my God
there is this idealized image of America
yeah immigrants need to have that sense
of identity that sense of community to
make sense of who you are
I tell my kids they can be different
they can be loud this is my way of
fighting for your own culture exactly
champagne pickles vodka my kind of party
we're all in these plates right here
salary will give you the unami taste
if you make it satisfied
um
easy girl I'll be back to hang with you
okay I'm sorry I can't help you there